riffing gaming way to be stay on roofing
gaming for a little while I so want to
see if this YouTube shirt worked oh yeah
it did it did work
Wow dude that [ __ ] is crazy oh this is
crazy
Griffin gerberg there is your live from
all things comedy studio Griffin gaming
[Laughter]
welcome ladies and gentlemen what's up
everybody
I'm over here trying to do this with the
wicked with with the with the crew it's
not a short stream somebody's like Short
Street you know I'm back already
you know all right guys this is Griffin
gaming as you can see because it says it
Griffin gaming live from live from the
all things comedy studio I'm there look
put a picture let's do this all right
let's get this money let's get this
money
I don't see it was good to be screening
track going again all right think P
sound of failure you have a great night
thanks for the donation we appreciate it
well thank you for the Dervish at the
wingman became that the wingman got a
wingman and isn't working all right Oh
anyways everybody while we're trying to
figure I gotta go ready sorry I bet
while we're doing that Oh ladies and
gentlemen repaired quit fat guy dying
all right that's enough of that
oops I turned myself off wait where's
the girlfriend Gaming guys this is a
work in progress I bet they're in here
death in this bunker
those guys oh my god that's got better
not truth like her I just checked it
sucking [ __ ]
using your character well you know what
the YouTube chat doesn't show up on the
know what's wrong anyways guys this is
this new game called dude job he picks
nudges head up and it's very diverse
just like a black guy two black girls
some robots no white guys no the two
white guys are wearing masks oh yeah KKK
people like hi dad
alright here we go guys this is so much
easier to jump cuz now I don't have to
do it we're gonna put guys hurt in there
you're not gonna go on the ship again
Danu the graphics on this fabric just
this hung up
look how beautiful this game is man
[Music]
that's ratcheting give me your energy
they're guys Wall Street feel they're
they're coming to artists decision
okay here we go here we go damnit guns
I'm flanking him whoa [ __ ] somebody
right there
[Music]
[Applause]
we're doing this how do you get you do
that oh my god well guys that's um yeah
just died quick on that hay gap if you
find any shield shin can you uh can you
bring it all right there we go
now it's just me and Pikachu our worst
fire team buddy oh we're here okay so in
the meantime let's go back to Griffin
gerberg makes me laugh I don't know why
makes me laugh so much anyways guys this
is we're Griffin gaming I'm here live at
the all things comedy studio I'm not so
this is gonna be my new thing I'm
calling all graphic artists out there if
you guys want to create a studio for me
you know let's do it and then I'll put
myself in it just like this so as hey we
are we how do we get out of this game I
don't want to watch this guy how do we
get out of this
okay leave match yeah we got to get out
of here all right so this is Cooper
gerberg I want to welcome wait a minute
be quiet I'm talking I want to say hello
to YouTube Thank You YouTube people I
want to say hello to twitch people we're
on right now so we're on YouTube twitch
and periscope and Facebook all at the
same time
Griffin gerberg I think I need a Griffin
gaming theme song if everybody's
interested so live from the all things
come to Italy okay ready I'm gonna do
ready okay oh yeah oh my god this guy
sent a way to hear that one that's gonna
be in the ders episode
ders is gonna be on he was on so I got a
good episode with him coming with that
designs yeah so I got a good one oh wait
I'll think of a different design - so
many designs which one it's not
detective designs is that is that the
one you're talking about
no the the beat maker his name's mph
the one we get a better camera - my yard
what are you selecting this guy that's
like
[Music]
would be that guy where am i that guy oh
I'm this guy the the Gib Gib orator
what's his name
wait before we go to the game
Griffin Gerber yeah but the guy was
telling you it's an mph design that's
the guy this game is called apex legends
yeah that's what this game is car no
nobody wants to play on a PC dude that's
just not fun I want to use a keyboard I
want to [ __ ] play with her goddamn
controller let go like a real man
wait there's that oh this is our ship
[ __ ] did you pick a place yeah let's go
dear quick chime going to Joe good game
Leon turn around we drop in oh look how
many people are going here look at all
those teams to the left there's one two
three yeah just get out of going right
below us right there in this building oh
man here yeah there we go
oh oh there's a thing right here oh yes
gun time gun time gun time well I'm
cocked back later maybe he's playing
with his friend he's like then they get
all they're not even paying attention to
us I don't like this [ __ ] alright
alright
is there anything up here aye sir
nothing up here man this big-ass roof
and there's no guns or anything you
should die from that dude they need to
change that wait what's this on the
ground okay I got another gun damn
there's no [ __ ] guns in you wait do I
have to the same gun okay no no I'm good
I'm good okay wait oh don't say it like
this somebody that where are you I can't
find okay there's our guys over here I
just went down I'm gonna go to I'm gonna
go all right
let's loot these houses right over here
I'm gonna put a marker wait let's go
this way brother with FX legends here
perks ledger I don't know why this this
game is so [ __ ] diverse welcome to
apex legend me and Pikachu
where are you did you go wait did you
use a zipline to go down I just jumped
down
okay wait yeah we're not that far away I
just jumped down I met these little like
oh you okay I'm going to this one's over
here oh my god this is oh no I'm gonna
be by myself this is a nightmare
oh yeah you'll be fine okay here we go
Oh somebody's in here the things open
okay where we get a help should take it
back no I got a helmet hey what is this
I don't want that gun oh [ __ ] there's
like a there's a shield oh there's a
bunch of [ __ ] right here wait John
I want this gun yeah okay
Oh what is all this Oh No maybe I won't
just good wait should I get rid of this
I don't know which gun is better
oh my god
I don't know JC I would have to look it
up there's a couple guys still here oh I
need a badass coke okay I'm coming you
can whine because somebody was here yeah
listen up me getting shot at oh you need
your vital to our party what is this
what is that ultimate accelerant oh [ __ ]
I got some kind of thing I got something
I think called the ultimate accelerant
real light oak oh my god I need a
backpack dude I'm not gonna be able to
do any what am I gonna do [ __ ] them up I
believe in you I mean it's like the
worst motivator if you don't mean yeah
peace who's the worst
are you inside this wait I'm coming [ __ ]
damn dude oh that's you know walking
card because he got hurt okay let's go
over here look at this there's like a
thing over here yes Anthony Pettis is
done that you have seen Wonder Boy oh my
god I can't go back I'm gonna swap out
what am i squish my swap out shotgun
shells oh I love that you could do that
that's like she dope flag grenade swap
out
oh [ __ ] what is this yeah okay
wait where are we if I shootin oh dude
there's a guy up like you like it
23:23 dude as a guy he dude he just shot
me [ __ ] twice what are you talking
about I'm coming don't worry dude
there's a guy shooting right here oh my
god I you're doing you're you're so bad
you don't I mean no what
well there's a guy shoot you're like
don't worry about it we mean don't worry
about it I'm just I'm getting shot at
let's just get into the circle get on
let's get out of here I don't like the
map the map should be like north west
south you know I mean oh here's another
thing look here's another big a case I
need a [ __ ] backpack man
what's the most prevalent injuries for
MMA it's probably their knees oh this
this taking everything yeah yeah yeah I
wouldn't have to say knees right on my
right Club yeah yeah yeah dude someone
is shooting right here it was her
teammate he's shot he shot is good I
even saw this his thing their teammate
okay who's that
oh [ __ ] this game just nerve-wracking
[Music]
yeah get the [ __ ] in stance where are
they where are they
there's a grenade are they inside this
building
I'm trying to flank you know where like
killing them right just a person
execution
Boompa clocked you Baumbach ah how do
you get a backpack I want a backpack
thank you brother
I got you brother wait I'm trying to get
inside here oh my god
oh my god Oh nightmare a nightmare that
was a nightmare all right I believe in
her teammate he's gonna cut it out he's
gonna kill him oh this guy just oh wow
this guy just revived us that was dope I
thought we were done
I don't was good I'm trying to get this
backpack oh here we go here we go here
we go yes oh this guy had a bunch of
good [ __ ] extended mag give me that um
what else oh that was dope that guy okay
how do I got a heel okay come to me I
have a hilly bottom now you're telling
me about the healing that okay
[Music]
yeah we're pretty terrible people on
YouTube a lot you guys are terrible yeah
okay thank you thanks for the heads up
yeah yeah as if we didn't like the label
ourselves terrible can jump I'm
surprised you've lasted like that okay
well you just gotta believe semi-decent
let's get us saved us what are you
talking he's Sam IDs let's go to the
[ __ ] how dare you [ __ ] okay it says
olb for shield I was pressing RB that's
so stupid yeah okay well that's why my
[ __ ] didn't work that time yeah guys
what's up this is Griffin gaming should
I get it oh my god in here right now if
you ever want a Griffin emo subscribe
worst fireteam ever on Twitch and we
haven't oh my god god this guy keeps
taking fire sounds good Jesus it's a
it's an oh my [ __ ] god well come to
me come to me alright here we go here we
go
there's a thing oh you did okay this is
young and welcome to Griffin gaming all
the way here I am live from the all
things comedy studio you know if you'd
like to make me a studio please send me
some images right now I'm in all things
comedy studio riffing with Griffin is up
there
so whatever you want to make alright
we're done I didn't do you know what
[ __ ] you don't be read must dad's [ __ ]
don't worry about my stats worry about
your [ __ ] okay
piece of [ __ ] let's let's get a champ in
here let's go champ
yeah you got to get in here choke send
me send me an invite invite me
okay did you I invited you brother I see
you Brad ah yes it's very ethnic this
apex legend is it should call it should
be called ethnic legends because it's
very much because not only is that girl
Asian on the Left she's black Asian I
like this
they've got blazing girls I like that
it's some kind of like weird yeah and
this middle guy is like weird - he's
like he's black also he's black Asian
this is like a de blasian game apex
blasian that's what should be called and
we're playing with Pikachu baby arms put
a bunch of I think not the worst player
isn't here right now
no aid ethnic Jews
are you ready for yeah turns apex edges
are we starting OS oh you waiting on me
my bad okay guys here we go again now we
got our guide this is worse far team all
together right now
Oh Pikachu far team that's a little logo
above me right there yeah a little logo
above me right there that's you should
click it to you like it and check it out
why you can't click it it doesn't have
any links attached to it
you should what sound she's a girl is
that a girl I can't
Wow maybe that could be a guy right no
that right maybe that's our first
transexual gaming player like you're
really going for it you know what it
means maybe that's our first none
our first non-binary character I'm
non-binary brother non-binary I know
what to do just tell me where to go
we're going there okay I see it
can we jump now no we should wait no
wait wait I don't know if those who
renato is
that's his last day he's legit Sugata
he's hella funny ready we could go there
alright let's go Renata
we said we should have got on that ship
right there so we can make this weekend
yeah no we can't make the ship you can't
make the show I'm sorry we can't make it
so we're going down here oh you guys
left but it's better when we're like Tim
got us your water all right come on mr.
mo no gun that [ __ ] is so infuriating
boy I have a gun who's that oh you
almost got blown the [ __ ] I tell you
guys stop sneaking up on me like you
lucky no ole thankfully in this game you
can't blast
I know friendly fire isn't on in this
game all right where do they gonna let
four people play dude I don't want just
three people play [ __ ] that's not good
it's not reloading
yet Kathy my god this is a war zone
well that was yeah I I am gonna have
green screen on my podcast and change
the background every week y'all I'm
asking you guys to send out some
backgrounds for me somebody make a
studio for me when I do my solo episodes
that's how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna get
a better camera it's an old-school
logitech right now but this is just for
gaming but anyways just go back to all
things comedy studio there we are I just
want to get a better one man
yeah just no no I had no I bought dude I
bought the cam link and [ __ ] doesn't
work actually I might get it but no I
just I really should just buy another
mag well but I don't want to spend
another $400 you know all right I'm
gonna do that yeah be nice to see your
freaking family this is ridiculous
I mean this mom comes in every time you
guys make me a studio I'm all about
making somebody make me a studio and
then I'm gonna use it on my podcast
already got some great theme song I hope
you
okay is he black or is he like samurai
some like I can't take yeah but his
voice was very like white guy but his
facial like I don't know this the
diversity on this game is ridiculous
guys because it's ethnic larger ethnic
legends the game with apex legends yeah
that middle one I don't I'm not sure
with that kind of kid and play haircut
let's do it we should just jump now and
go like right here yeah let's just get
out so we don't have like a bunch of
teams coming out
the same picture legends game was not
that bad still I can't pick a theme song
guys because the theme songs that are
coming in or SoDo every week I get
somebody tops the masked person so I
can't pick eventually I'm gonna have a
pole discussion and we'll do it this
long bow there we go somebody took
Pikachu that's what he does man yeah
like you're clearly standing right there
yeah yeah you standing right there
and he just ones up on ya he doesn't
even acknowledge it either he's just
like oh [ __ ] okay I need today is not us
oh [ __ ] who's a Jamaican chick man
[ __ ] dude these people keep running up
on me that's how you get blasted alright
I got my thumb right every good I need a
shield or something Bobby are Griffin or
Bobby or Steve shaker create Griffin's
theme song I don't know that would be
dope
I want Steve that'd be nicer Steve made
me want to write you know what when you
have Bobby and Steve all you should have
one movie like theme song right that's
the next one we're gonna be doing Scotty
Duffy's I think I'm gonna have them on
yeah I'm gonna record that episode next
week I think are you guys following me
cuz I'm just following the thing here's
another building right here oh here's
some [ __ ] here's some of these big
crates oh yes there it is y'all whoo a
frag grenade wait what gun is this does
this gun better I don't know which gun
is better ask Oh Kermie
let's go that's right guys - that's
right oh I like how the a shield pops up
when you shoot with this guy
this guy's pretty good yeah no yes he's
really good
he takes more damage - he's not as fast
but you might be something good this way
oh there's a lot of chests over here
look at this
well we're totally rate in this area
what's this [ __ ] already yeah I'm taking
it from this to this so I don't want
that okay can you ask what happened to
his podcast and when is cooking it be on
Wi-Fi or if it is any town when he comes
into town yeah there's people there's
people there's people where where where
where oh did you okay I'm 15 I'm getting
shot at okay brothers we need assistance
hey hey we gave me a hang of it maybe we
should switch over to back to call the
duty yeah Pete she's really bad at call
duty well he's no better at this this
game he's like so crazy thinking he
thinks he is well maybe he's maybe as
long as he has confidence in the game
then maybe that's all that's all that
needs to happen right if he feels like
he's good he's good I'm connecting in
the lobby
oh my god all right let's go back to all
things comedy studio Oh
how do we do that how do we get here
because it's Griffin gar burn oh thank
you oh then we have to stop should I
stop connecting to match oh okay all
right
I'm an old things comedy how did I get
here oh my god what I'm not in yet yes
lag in big-time
yes I'm saying it I don't even see you
on like its rear okay I'm gonna go to
pikachu's game brah
Griffin Derby huh oh yeah we got keep
playing oh here we go
ooh more tales new do is that [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] easy bro yeah this may be
this is good okay I'm maybe this is a
white guy and he has a really dark tan
like he went on vacation
dude he's clearly so you think so Samoan
dude yeah but listen to his voice dude
what you hear his voice do we can't
start without you it's like we have to
cancel like cancelled out okay it was an
error again
what the [ __ ] go ready I'm ready
how's the mic sound everybody know how
to mic if the volumes get what's
happening give me some feedback give me
some feedback chat yeah and they're
saying coke Lestat powder I don't think
cokes a snap powder hell no he is I play
with these dudes you wouldn't you said
think that's such a guy yeah he's mister
instigator man Facebook check this chat
that I could see all the chats is really
dope he didn't want to win he was
playing with me and God play the game
alright here we go just us two left and
we got second again oh you know what I
could do oh man I can actually FaceTime
call you coke and you're a face could be
on the screen I could just have like a
little face show of you yeah that's how
we could do it yeah yeah yeah I didn't
want to beat
and abroad ah the big Samoan runner the
blazing girl tonight check out his
brandy pretty much out there dude your
Stan ever allowed multi-player I'll go
again speak to and I'll [ __ ] ice in
every single time and he knows it
I play aggressive as [ __ ] Pete you play
super passive so I don't
going to forgive me energy
my [ __ ] where are you
right here man alright there's hella
people here let me tell the people here
okay so my bad I'll bet I'm over here
looking at the [ __ ] computer all
right all right no I shot something
there's a triple take my triple take
right here
I I got it oh no I didn't a good girl
let's go let's go
therefore we need you we need your
shields and [ __ ] wait dude I'm trying to
get can I get guns so I can be usefull
die in the middle wait oh my god there's
a guy I didn't see this guy's there's
two guys to the right and 11 no there's
still one more guy 14 14 where are you
guys just call no it's crawled up I'm
coming
oh god they're shooting at me I got a
zig-zag crawl oh man oh God
well that was terrible
got one yeah yeah he's healing himself
with a big dude right next to him I was
telling you I get two people down man I
can't I can't do it myself dude I was
trying I was there I was shooting at
that guy I don't know you got so far
behind this game dude these games I just
can't I can't I don't know what it's
like
there's too much you have to do you know
you're like reload put your shield up
you know crawl it's like [ __ ] then I'm
trying to I'm trying to get my grenade I
don't know which [ __ ] button the
grenade is it's annoying you know I
don't need your commentary YouTube
YouTube telling you you don't know me
alright here we go alright how does it
make don't forget you have an element
escape
oh that's right I did forget about 2 lb
in the LBC man adapt movin begats
Griffin's character really looks like I
don't know
is such a basis in introducing your
champion
you know jumpmaster brother i'm the
jumpmaster yes finally some really good
we could do something good right let's
go here good feeling about this area how
do you launch launch oh [ __ ]
are these people going to the same place
yep
what's Freehan
one dropped early to drop the other way
okay come on let's do this oh my god I'm
so nervous nervous time oh [ __ ] you
somebody right here already he's already
getting good oh my god oh my god has
already got a gun oh Jesus Christ
shooting [ __ ] out of me dude I'm taking
fire somebody where are your folks
oh I'm down oh jeez oh my god oh my god
oh man anyways I want to say hello to
twitch
say hello to Facebook right say hello to
periscope and YouTube guys we're doing
it all at once with restream it's pretty
dope it's peridot
[Music]
it's pretty dope out here in this be get
out there all right
anything this guy put a shield up yep
help he's on me I have no ammo thank you
where the [ __ ]
don't even get me started he's on his
own like he out here or in these streets
all by himself just killing somebody we
Pete shoot that's why you have you go
for thirst [ __ ] kills kills that are
already you guys are shooting the gun
rabbika killed in your teammates out
g-good are we good yeah hey I agreed
Nate whoo there is a real learning curve
on this game
this is this is impossible
alright let's go to we're gonna go this
is Phoenix this is Erica
UFC fighter I'm super watching now
because we control my [ __ ] go crazy
energy accents are really driving me
bananas
mmm why you don't be mad brother and we
can't revive Griffin [ __ ] oh yeah like
you're gonna revive me piece of [ __ ]
yeah of course
hey Greg Koch let's take this over here
Laurita place yeah I know I know I'm
taking it brother nobody's watching me
on periscope
yeah sure each lead uh no no you two
became a people to watch I know they
can't even revive because I'm doing Oh
Wicky how do you get that [ __ ] going
again
a long long jumps yeah yeah it's gettin
it's gettin to be about that point while
they're doing that let's go back to the
all things comedy studio guys Wow
Griffin Goodman you guys all know Bob
Pikachu but he has called ethnic letting
up me you shooting at me mark Elmo
invited me to a party
I keep getting invited so ridiculous I I
don't like we're playing you don't mean
there's a lemon squash you're like whoa
I invited maybe he'll invite me I know
oh yeah
leave what we're doing to go be with you
guys welcome to you need like mo III got
energized
well this is what I do sometimes I'm on
here game in with the boys with fire
team if you could chew and coke right
now you know accents okay all right take
that take that we got [ __ ]
melted well that was terrible so fast
this game's not bad and it's like I feel
like it's a little fort 90 though with
the movement and stuff man I I feel like
the clips and the guns like unless you
get like a [ __ ] it suit like an
extended match like you have like ten
bullets in an automatic gun I know no
sense no no we just do a today maybe
tomorrow we'll do black ops but today is
just Apex legends we want to just get
some good gaming in on this new game
thank everybody for being a part of the
magic why isn't it starting Thompson
subscribed or sparked a lever
- you guys what is that that's me that's
right guys you're watching a pika TV
pika Pikachu - pika TV all these folks
try to add you Jesus oh no there's too
much well I got 132 people watching on
YouTube that's nice I got like 20
oh here we go oh no dude who's a total
that's just to do from Compton man he's
definitely from Inglewood obscure and
Hardy legends yes I'm jump master give
the job master better you should can I
get some brothers in the chat please I
know everyone on this bench can I get a
pogchamp in the twitch chat please
actually let's hit the [ __ ] hard what's
you all the [ __ ] this feel Kanta yet us
do that like that like going on the ship
okay
I'm scared brother
Oh chalupa thank you again for another
$5 donation this game Waterloo on thank
you
oh we're gonna hit this ship great but
then these [ __ ] teams come flying out
and okay there's a team to our left
heading for the ship yeah
oh they're gonna get their own [ __ ] is
another two you oh [ __ ] her gun I can't
get a guy oh my god jumped off that's
great oh good call coke good call but
these guys might jump off to come get us
oh there's a guy right here who's that
what I got took off there's a guy that
took off well there's no guns dude just
no frickin guns here oh my god I hate
not having a gun so naked naked and
afraid in my gun got one I need a gaming
phone Sam I [ __ ] her up we put that
out there I did a gaming theme song cuz
I'm gaming
mmm gaming with Griffith oh here we go
wanna go over here yeah okay there's
like a rush stuff just like a Russian
guy did you hear that guy okay - I
finally have a gun I finally have a
frickin gun this guy keeps [ __ ]
sending messages do you want to get
blocked dude you got to get blocked let
me block this dude I'm about to block
his ass if someone will cover my banner
that'd be great
are you already dead oh my god this
piece of [ __ ] dude
I killed two people because you gotta
get block yeah
mark Mull 101 [ __ ] you don't don't talk
[ __ ] Tim though cuz you'll get banned
she just reporters block his ass how do
you do it look at guys spamming hi good
pork person how do you block them I just
want to block what person I think
doesn't work I just want to block this
to you how do you [ __ ] block people
everyone you see this gamertag harass
them [ __ ] annoying dude oh yeah I
don't know no view profile I think he
kept you his profile oh that's how you
do it okay I'm actually in a middle yeah
I'll do it after this cuz he stopped
we're in an intense game of regressive I
mean typical it's okay my batter timed
out I'm sorry everyone watching pika TV
I failed you two okay we're all right
where's coke I'm like off on my own here
I'm [ __ ] looting all this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] what is this I don't know what that
was is this a better gun now when you
pick up another gun wait does it keep
the ammo from the go yes see you yes it
does brother okay I don't know if I want
this shotgun yes I do is this a shotgun
better than I have which one are you
that one's good at Auto [ __ ] okay
rings not far all right just a bunch of
[ __ ] oh no oh [ __ ] what is this ultimate
accelerant what does that do oh yes it's
right in front of your face it makes
sure we're gonna be charged at time
it'll shoot faster faster I'm [ __ ] in
the world I don't like the map dude but
not I just sort of figured it out like
where the arrow is pointing that's where
you go almost an almost dead
where I'm coming for you guys right now
okay for you guys
I got my super oh [ __ ] the ring is
closing oh my god we're right by it but
brother you gotta go and coming you're
fine you're fine or literally right I
see it's gonna that's been looted these
are closed and they're headed towards
you no I'll be right back Stream I'm
gonna get some snacks where are you
gonna get some snacks we're in the
middle of a game oh you did oh no you're
dead he's bummed dad oh [ __ ] I got like
three or two kills me kills don't don't
do that cook again you have to time it
correctly income yeah
[Laughter]
wait how do we get oh it's just some
kind of way through this [ __ ] oh yeah
okay here we go
does I can opening over here coke where
I'm at we'll meet when it's time to move
forward
let's check this way yeah we can go now
it doesn't look like there's much much
going on around here oh yeah there's a
whole thing right here a chest so
nobody's open so we're like hey there's
a crate over here to go oh they missed
you so much
so many people were like I got some
pretzel pretzel mmm literally nobody
said that
oh look my famous there's another one
there Santa like sniper stock and a
sniper or six times sniper scope I don't
have a sniper [ __ ] my [ __ ] backpack
to fall to just a full with nonsense
alright next circle and go through this
there's not another chest I have I have
a kit kat bar right here what would you
do for a kit kat bar that's not the
right jingle and I got a recent Klondike
bar
yes whatever I [ __ ] wanted to be
goddammit what would you do for a
Snickers
dude I'm just going oh [ __ ]
Oh put it up oh man
stop talking to me Pikachu you're dead
so annoying did I even get a kill I
killed him remember lb and you can so
you said you got three kills yeah yeah
one [ __ ] [ __ ] booster two [ __ ]
boosting over here to join like three
kills
he got one guy down and he tried to
thirst the hell out he gets a guy down
and he just [ __ ] tries to kill oh my
god not worried about anything else
going on around the start guys let's go
back to all things comedy welcome back
to Griffin gaming do you mean quick a so
you can be the girl that can teleport
once why don't use a different cursor
right yeah what are you talking about
this isn't making sense what you're
saying oh excuse me sorry Chad I've been
looking at the chat
Oh is there something going on with the
audio in the video
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all like you got one do you using
this sexy bedroom voice that must be me
what's up how you doing - sexy bedroom
[Music]
wait is it my turn to pick [ __ ]
around singing and even get to pick I
have one kill if you have 70 and 80
kills this isn't right oh my god you
know what I love people to think they
love to tell me how to do my [ __ ] you
know I mean you should do this I think
you should you know do it this way [ __ ]
your face you know what get off my
[ __ ] stream we're going to the ship
yeah the Lee brothers are coming on
again and we're gonna be talking about
movies again soon black they're coming
on to the left cuz we gonna do it once a
month it's only been like three three
and a half weeks y'all get ready moving
on wait how can I say two of us
oh do look at all the teams on the ship
again you loop then get off oh my god oh
come get the [ __ ] out of here
come on oh my god this is so nerve okay
here we go here we go
[ __ ] can I get a gun give me a [ __ ]
gun that guy shot me I need some healing
here we go yes look at all this yes what
is that
Oh [ __ ] why you shoot you don't just
come runnin up on me like that
god I'm running the coke I don't want to
die that's gonna help because you
there's a lot of shooting going on over
here
what is that oh [ __ ] oh my god damn it
so fury ating put up that shield let's
watch Pikachu what are you doing just
throw it I don't know if do you think
Steve's playing this game is free
I wonder Steve glandt I gotta take it
out it what does he even play these days
you plan who the [ __ ] knows yeah what
game is Dee playing these days I'm
getting back from the right I'm gonna
text two's guys I'm gonna text Bobby and
Steve I don't know they need to play
they can neither one of them like eat
you what you just did right there like
that's the [ __ ] we're never gonna win a
game if you don't push people you sit so
far back
like I was not trying to say far better
babe in my defense you know there's no
defense to your horrible gameplay okay
you can't defend it your teammates are
dead they're all dead
okay Griffin I hear your pitch man just
leave me alone for right now okay we're
just trying these games out I'm testing
it out this is the infancy of my podcast
okay you know I'll just try and [ __ ] out
so listen can you just give me a break
god everyone else welcome to Griffin
Gate Entertainment go burn you know what
your problem is because you we tell you
what your problem is okay I'll be quiet
I'm sorry
okay yeah this guy why they all look
like they're like he's like doing like a
[ __ ] squat cuz I'm a boss I'm changing
characters the non-binary character
[Laughter]
you're hella good okay God well how do
you get to smoke grenades lb lb okay
watch out for my squad if I were you oh
of course coke she's a full-time DPS
chasing those kills for stats I'm
relinquishing this Craig Jesus we're
going either no I'm not
Oh what happened I relinquished I'm
jumping just follow me
the follicle where is he I can't see him
oh there he is
he's already leaving us this is exactly
what happens oh [ __ ] I got a jump master
thing I'm not gonna go here cuz you guys
are there I'm not taking I get the auto
shop first blood
give me a gun I don't want oh my god
dude [ __ ] next to something that's not
good
okay here we go what is this I'm coming
to you guys here I come
I think I painted brother how do you get
up there just come with just come right
here hold [ __ ] where all this thing just
hold you up this you want a shotgun to
come get it why are you mark I see wait
wait do I have by do I do I have this
song new kill leader
sniper stock over here coke if you get
its name
well can I die got to [ __ ] hankins
that's actually like this I got this
[ __ ] people trying to send me I don't
want to play with you I'm playing right
now God people are pieces of [ __ ] no all
right opened up this oh it's dinner mag
yes right give us your energy chat
devotion you guys okay no there's two
crates over here there's another crib
and I didn't take all the stuff in that
other crate oh [ __ ] mag energy weapon
okay all right
don't come over here then notice nothing
in here oh [ __ ] there's a auto shot
again yes yes give me that a mouthful oh
[ __ ] look at the graphics on this man
I'm all the note in the water who got
the full auto mod prowler business boy
did you guys go in this building right
here this gun is a hundred percent of
ripoff Mikaela yes it literally looks
exactly like it oh here we go here we go
what is this Griffon stay with us
Griffin stay was we're gonna go on the
ship Griffin where are you oh here I put
a ping I put a ping I'm coming you guys
left some [ __ ] over here yeah we don't
need that [ __ ] you think anyone's on
this Creek cook
um come ashore I'm gonna take the ride
[ __ ] I got my shotgun people like I
want to see my gamertag pop up on the
screen guys just stop [ __ ] I feel like
it's been looted already yes man I got a
grenade oh you got a grenade hey blue oh
yeah yep there's nothing where I'm at
here coke coke coke
why are you [ __ ] here take this give
me that give me the blue one you're the
best player bet that should tell you
maybe you need more armor
kind of where we're at bumbaclot
that's right stream I'm a clot all right
we're in the circle all there's some
unopened crates over here oh yeah a
bunch of them I know Kurt's only reading
no I'm reading all the chats guys I
could see you in the twitch I'm reading
the Twitter all the chats coming to one
chat that's pretty dope about this eye
twitch chat I could see you stop being
little [ __ ] you know pogchamp twitch
chat feels all like oh [ __ ] folks hella
far away okay we gotta get to him we
gotta get something gonna get to him oh
I can't even [ __ ] kidding me these
backpacks don't hold enough [ __ ] man
where are we going where is he I don't
know where he is oh here we go
extended light mag good [ __ ] I needed
that
hey there's gunfight over here okay bro
oh I see him you see where they're
fighting I'm gonna know cuz we're not
even new yeah but we're on our way
I mean of course Jesus of course how are
you guys so far back because we were
looking at [ __ ] man pick it up opening
up crates and stuff
I want this gun we got a drop on this
team over here yes still just [ __ ]
hey what's up Vince ain't show Bob chill
machine oh my god
here we come look so nice he's super
focused no I might YouTube is better
than twitch i agree but i'm also on
periscope so you don't even know about
that game yeah i don't know about that
periscope gained put up a shield
hey are we shooting them with a grenade
all pass B that's sugar I don't see him
they started it oh there he is got me
down I'm shooting at Pikachu where is it
oh [ __ ]
what it just happens why am i burning up
well we were like in a bomb zone yeah
but you owe my god you yelling at me
like your shield throw your smoke
grenade did you use your ultimate like
shut up man [ __ ] I hate you so much
seriously where are we where are we
bigger to where are we so close
it's crazy only seven people are trying
to which I'm sure they're just getting
furious just giving oh my god dude oh
one more game
one more game this is it guys one more
game then we're out and I want to thank
you for coming to riffin Griffin gaming
[Music]
live from all things comedy studio
Griffin gaming
and thank you for your patience [ __ ]
face man muddy Compton guy again time to
end this
sho'nuff that's shown up from last
dragon nobody got a turn man he went to
the salon he got his straighten
this is your champion this is your
champion
I'm the jumpmaster Gophers right there
go for the [ __ ] [ __ ] we're go for the
chip Oh
somebody's saying he's Mexican I can
believe that he could be Mexican he's
not Mexican Mexicans don't say that he's
some own ass freak
Jesus there's a gun right here I'm down
but I jumped can you guys come the guy
shot me when I was on the [ __ ] when I
jumped off and he got me wait this is my
[ __ ] me oh my god well recover you
will recover you mean Coco getting guns
and will recoveries oh my god you can't
recover me I'm dead you can't mean
weaken over your banner we can recover
your banner revive me photo oh my god
ping my [ __ ] okay just pinged my banner
coke let's go enough uh I mean I don't
have [ __ ] i'm a peacekeeper man chat is
just [ __ ] they're just ruthless man I
hate this chat I love you chat on a rock
that is accurate as [ __ ] [ __ ] you I know
I should have just jumped off but I got
cocky because I had a gun and I was
shooting right after guy you guys saw
that I was right there there's a girl
right there holy must be AFK Mirage well
if you hadn't been bullshitting me you
just came right to me we wouldn't have
this problem now you know wow this is
what this is my teammates right now you
could have but you could have got me up
the thing is right there - [ __ ] you're
the worst
I know but like a team we should just
kill ourselves we could do one more game
of Griffin I mean we gotta find somebody
okay alright let's let's just go guns
blazing over here down the roof yeah
this guy guys while they're doing that I
just wanna say welcome to Griffin Gerber
so make sure you guys stay tuned in it's
a Griffin gaming watch Pikachu's
gameplay is that guy oh that's the worst
shot ever you can see what are you doing
I'm just gonna have a 3xk nice long gone
let's move that to kill that guy what
are you making a phone call
what is that oh you better die you guys
right there Oh
open the door will quicken in to get
jump back oh [ __ ] why you reloading you
hadn't even shot yet now I see the prey
shoot your gun terrible guys it's what
you are you are all witness are all
witness to this oh my god
to the face you go looking for it I
don't have any donate links on my
[ __ ] Eric Griffin comedy page guys
sorry
thank you but thank you for watching if
you want to if you want to donate please
go to worst fire team then you could
donate if you would like dudes like I'm
trying to give you my life is there
anybody in there Oh was he just kind of
like a limp look like a sex robot did
you see that oh man that was not a go
there you go
you are the new team Kiwi you could
possibly get Pikachu oh this is so
nerve-racking right now this is our UFC
fighter friend Erik no way alright guys
thank you for watching
Griffin game a oh god alright we're
gonna do one more
I was doing my outro guy one more
Gruffudd coming my booty is hurtin
sitting on this chair I'm having booty
problems y'all yeah I don't know if any
gaming chair companies out there would
like to donate yeah like where to [ __ ]
these don't
where these chair companies that out
here bullshitting y'all oh sorry
here we go we are with ethnic legends
this is gonna be a good fight
all right do I pick Oh
oh really oh is that how you get to
enable super super chat is how you
donate oh I didn't know that okay I got
it
why why can't I have it so this
[ __ ] you here just do yeah I
need like a booty pillow if there's a
booty pillow company out there oh [ __ ]
I'm still on this back to the game
stream here we are y'all Coco the
jumpmaster I know he's taking this far
away all right gene this is wrong - well
we're gonna go really far this match
prepare for battle
this the last one for me regardless
let's do it
where's the door in this [ __ ] there we
go
and then they'd all [ __ ] fence Jesus
okay good this was [ __ ] in here though
Oh peacekeeper right off the [ __ ] bat
let's go okay let's sing here oh [ __ ]
what is this I don't know what this is
but I'll take it
we got extended mag give me that frag
hello hello oh [ __ ] I got a bunch of
shop there's footprints over here
there's someone over here I was over
here no I don't know man oh man I need
to what should i swap out I don't know
what this hit Oh sniper stop
I was not over here I was not over here
I was not over here yeah yeah okay where
are you guys okay
this game looks beautiful though I gotta
say again oh wait somebody right here
where'd he go oh my god
oh my god kill that [ __ ] yes
shoot there's somebody else coming
there's somebody else there though right
there one over here boys
oh my god I'm hurt laughing okay wait I
gotta use how do i oh my god I'm so
confused right now
I gotta recharge my shield again
I'm gonna have the healing thing in ten
seconds okay okay I'm just picking up
these [ __ ] grenades all right here we
go
[ __ ] that was a blast zone right there
guys I came in dad they got to put the
circle like all the way on the opposite
[ __ ] side every time well you don't
[ __ ] Jew oh [ __ ] we gotta go as hella
far away I had I had no idea it's gonna
be this far this is ridiculous
brothers we gotta go let's go we gotta
go guys well you guys that you know
where you guys are at oh wait you know
what oh we have to go up here there we
go here we go if you hold a Y Griffin
you can holster your weapon you can run
a little faster oh [ __ ] okay go brother
oh that's nice you learn something new
every day
like stupid far away holy [ __ ] we're
going on a [ __ ] marathon
what the [ __ ] my god
well there's some shooting up here I'm
sure don't worry about it I'm I'm
confident in this oh did you hear that
Griffin Peters confident yeah
he's calm look at this though I'm
grabbing this give me that blue backpack
don't give me this
I'll take I can't even take that all
right we got to go we can't be over here
[ __ ] around yeah we can't be
dilly-dally
ring is closing we're not gonna make it
this is this is nonsense right now
nonsense look how far away are we oh my
god just keep running just keep running
I'm running we're gonna be fine what's
gonna happen is we're gonna run into
like another group like we're so far
away oh my god care package I love these
things
care package
hey I think I made a wrong turn
no we're good we're good here we go damn
Pikachu's character got a booty owner
huh look at that wagon taste give me a
girl come here don't you run for me
don't you run from me
she can't even run properly cuz that
booty is just wiggling you could do side
piers or sit-ups but please don't lose
that but actually that's actually a
fanny pack huh just people shooting to
the right to the south there's gunfire
to the south
yeah these things already opened the way
for Coke wait for call wait for deer I'm
not doing any place I'm gonna talk
follow me come back to me come we need
to get into the circle I'm going there
there's teams over here though where I'm
almost in the circle in the outskirts
here I'll just ease right here
oh I can't believe I put that shield up
oh they came in my suit and killed me
what's the point of a shield if
[ __ ] can just come in and kill
you
I know Pikachu is so damn bossy
let's come come an attempt to get us up
your banner I'm gonna make it into the
zone and they fight they're shooting my
body
you can do it though
I think you can get me dude all right
there oh that's beautiful
what the [ __ ] gun is that that gun is a
beast
damn it that's that's if you get a good
shot with that gun
that's liked by all right guys that has
been Gryphon gaming with worst fire team
does Pikachu and Coke pika can I do my
outro first before you look [ __ ] do
your [ __ ] outro god man you just
ruined I got do it all over again
shut up Griffon Gerber alright thanks
guys for watching and we'll have some
more I got a big keep watching rhythm
with Griffin cuz I got on ders from
workaholics coming up next so look out
for him on Monday if you like you some
on ders only one person left Adams when
he gets back into town i'ma get Adam and
also Wayman is coming on the show guys
Wayman so look out for Wayman yeah so
that you you'd be surprised how much
that [ __ ] talks alright guys
this is Griffin gaming out